what goes in to portraying a murderer
added actor Evan Peters prepare for the
role of one of the most notorious Mass
killers in recent history what was Ryan
Murphy's one rule for dramatizing real
life events keep watching to find out
all the details Dahmer monster the
Jeffrey Dahmer story a title which is
only marginally less convoluted than
High School Musical the musical the
series is a Netflix biographical crime
drama about the titular Infamous real
world serial killer Jeffrey Dahmer the
series tells the story through the lens
of those affected by his criminal
activities rather than by focusing on
the murderer himself that alone is a
refreshing take on the genre as most
dramas based on real and dangerous
people toe the line between retelling
events and romanticizing them
fortunately in this case the exact
opposite is occurring as the cast has
been open about their experience with
the production star Evan Peters in
particular has come forward about the
process which saw him become the Killer
and precious little of what he has to
say can be misconstrued by even the most
Ardent True Crime apologists here's what
he shared about the acting process in an
interview shared by Netflix's YouTube
accounts Evan Peters shared a familiar
struggle stating that portraying the
serial killer Jeffrey Dahmer deeply
taxed him he said honestly I was very
scared about all of the things that he
did and diving into that and trying to
commit to that was absolutely going to
be one of the hardest things I've ever
had to do in my life because I wanted it
to be very authentic but in order to do
that I was going to have to go to really
dark places and stay there for an
extended period of time trivia like this
feels double edged on one hand behind
the scenes information is usually
compelling simply on the Merit that
someone in the know is pulling the
curtain aside so that curious minds can
potentially access it on the other hand
it's not particularly surprising or even
interesting news to hear that a normal
person is disturbed by pretending to be
a serial killer if anything that should
just be the daily litmus test where
anyone taking on these roles the moment
it doesn't phase you it's time to switch
actors right all this aside it's
heartening to know that Peters is
putting in the work to ensure that his
projects are as good as it can possibly
be and maybe that's the only important
takeaway from this because anything else
sounds suspiciously like someone
complaining about one of the coolest
jobs in the world while the role Force
Devin Peters to go to some Dark Places
the actor was always wary of making sure
his character was presented in an honest
and very unflattering light that said he
wasn't the only person involved in the
creation of Dahmer monster the Jeffrey
Dahmer story who felt this way going
into the series during the
aforementioned interview with Netflix
Peters revealed that co-creator Ryan
Murphy had one rule with this project
never glamorized the titular serial
killer according to Peter is not
betraying Dahmer as a protagonist means
that the audience can't see his point of
view and potentially sympathize with his
plight Peters explained it's called the
Jeffrey Dahmer story but it's not just
him and his backstory it's the
repercussions it's how society and our
system failed to stop him multiple times
because of racism homophobia it's just a
tragic story everybody gets their side
of the story told that it felt important
to be respectful to the victims to the
victims families overall the goal was to
detail the experiences of his victims
and others involved in the disturbing
case Peter said that dalmer's story is
quote so much bigger than the serial
killer and that's what the show's cast
and crew hopes viewers take away from
the series
[Music]